House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi is
leading a Democratic delegation into the
heart of the immigration storm tonight
they're visiting a border facility where
children are being held national
correspondent William la jeunesse is in
San Diego right now this is not about
immigration this is about humanity it's
about family it's about who we are as a
country
for days Democrats fanned out across the
country to hammer president Trump's
zero-tolerance immigration policy it's
appalling it's not American it's
unnecessary but it's also not new the
decision to prosecute any and all who
crossed the border illegally actually
began as a pilot program under President
Bush in 2006 the zero tolerance policy
is intended to deter people from
breaking the law
Manny Padilla was chief patrol agent in
Tucson when President Obama expanded
operations streamline increasing
prosecutions some 200 percent which
advocates claim helped reduce illegal
immigration today the Trump
administration makes the same case we
cannot and will not encourage people to
bring their children or other children
to the country unlawfully by giving them
immunity in the process the
administration also hopes zero tolerance
will reduce fraud we do not have the
luxury of pretending that all
individuals coming to this country as a
family unit are in fact a family
Homeland Security claims illegal
immigrants fraudulently using children
to pose as family increased 315 percent
this fiscal year exploiting a loophole
to escape deportation in prosecuting
those cases the department separated
some 1,200 children from an adult the
smugglers and traffickers know these
loop holders loopholes better than our
members of Congress critics say Trump is
separating children not to change the
law but as a bargaining chip to fund his
wall how is it possible that we don't
have a president who would rescind this
zero inhumanity policy immediately
so moments ago the administration stress
that entering the u.s. without
permission is a crime and basically the
problem is is that when you detain women
and children the courts have said that
you have to release them within 20 days
the administration wants Congress to
close that loophole so families can stay
together but when we heard Brett from
Democrats today is they want to ban this
practice and they believe that family
should be handled administratively not
criminally buckey's William Lodge nest
in San Diego William thank you